lick a toad and vomit out a cat because
we have one of the strangest shows i've
ever seen netflix's brand new cherry
flavor is a wild ride of blood magic and
revenge that is so twisted it had me
questioning what i'm doing with my life
so naturally i decided to do a video on
it in this video we'll be taking a deep
dive into brand new cherry flavor
answering some of its most unanswered
questions and whatever the hell this is
now if you haven't seen the show this
video might be a bit hard to follow but
that's simply because the show is
absolutely insane and before we begin
make sure to like and subscribe
seriously only seven percent of you are
subscribed because who knows what messed
up shows i'll be covering next the final
episode aptly titled bodies begins five
months before the main events of the
show boro a 900 year old witch from the
jungles of south america performs tarot
when she senses an odd presence we'll
later learn she's sensing the show's
protagonist lisa nova you see borrow is
looking for a new host in episode 6 we
learn about boro's origin story 900
years ago boro who at the time was a man
encountered a white jaguar in the jungle
who was imbued with a magical spirit
they had sex because that's what you do
when you encounter a spirit jaguar and
it must have been so good that the
jaguar imparted to him a bit of her
power he becomes this great warrior and
leader until one day he learns of a
rival army on its way to destroy him so
the jaguar makes him an offer the
ability to see where his enemies are in
exchange for him sacrificing his wife
the princess but boro wants to have his
cherry-flavored cake and eat it too he
attempts to trick the jaguar by offering
a different woman in his wife's place
but the jaguar sees past this deceptive
ruse as a result of his treachery the
jaguar maulsboro to a bloody bulb and
just before borrow is about to die for
reasons that are unexplained in the show
boro was able to transfer himself into a
new body this is likely a result of the
small bit of jaguar spirit he had
previously been given so basically for
900 years boro has been hopping from
body to body while trying to evade the
spirit of the jaguar exactly so borah
wants lisa as her new host and lures her
in by offering her anything she wants
and lisa wants two things to get her
film back into exact revenge on
washed-up hollywood producer lou burke
you see lisa is a struggling filmmaker
who has just completed her first short
film entitled lucy's eye it's a funny
play on words the title lucy's eye
because at the end of the film lou can't
see it gained the attention of lou who
optioned the film for ten thousand
dollars and told her she could direct
the feature but when lisa is unreceptive
to lose unwanted sexual advances he
hires a new director and takes her story
from her lisa didn't exactly have the
best friends go over her contract and
lou basically has full control to do
whatever he wants so lisa wants revenge
and borrow with her magic can give it to
her over 8 episodes we see how this tale
of revenge spirals out of control where
those close to lisa get hurt like jules
who is burned alive or her ex-boyfriend
code who is brutally stabbed in the face
the same is true for lou whose life
takes a turn for the worse he gets a
nasty eye infection his son dies only to
be returned as a zombie and he too loses
control of the movie this is all led up
to the final episode where lisa is shot
by a bounty hunter paid by lou only to
seek refuge in a trap door in her
apartment that mysteriously appeared
after she performed borrow's ritual in
episode 3. in it is a white jaguar
skinned couch in episode 6 boro said
that's what the white jaguar turned into
after it was killed by the spanish yet
the spirit of the jaguar remains in a
world beyond their own lisa says of the
trapdoor that it transports her
someplace else it's like i close my eyes
and
i'm back in brazil in fact you may have
noticed that as the episodes of the
series progress her apartment gets more
and more covered in jungle-like vines in
the basement where the door leads she
finds this faceless woman who she
believes could be her mother she spoke
to me
who borrow
my mother
or something that wants me to think it's
my mother lisa herself isn't quite sure
this is actually her mother or if it's
some sort of manifestation of her mother
controlled by the jaguar spirit but it
is heavily implied lisa shares some
connection with it that's why boro is
obsessed with lisa her blood somehow
sustains her that's why she takes all
those kittens as the faceless woman says
the night lisa took peyote while on her
film shoot and unlocked something within
her which is how boro sensed her but it
unlocked this door in me that
i didn't know was locked boro says of
this thing inside lisa you have
something inside you
it's tasty i should also mention that in
episode 7 when the spirit touches lisa
it sucks out the poison she got from
licking that toad in episode 6. not
mentioned but implied is that the spirit
then gives that poison to boro which is
why she declines quite rapidly in the
show's last episode and has to switch
bodies but back to brazil and lisa's
mother lisa's mother left her when she
was a child and all lisa has of hers is
a faceless photo notice the cat here
cats play a large role in the series
showing up as tattoos on her body the
things she pukes out and is even the
first image we see in episode 1. lisa is
like the cat helpless weak and stalked
by larger prey here we have her in
episode 1 at wolf's petrol stalked by
one of boro's minions but as lou says in
episode 1 but this world we live in
is predators and prey
and each and every one of us is
both lisa is not only the cat she can be
a predator in episode six she viciously
kills jimmy someone sent to kill her and
as she does you can even make out the
sounds of a jaguar lisa's motivation to
direct her own movie stems from her want
to find her mother
i feel like if i can
make my film
somehow she'll see it
and she'll know it came from me at the
end of the series we see her book a
flight to brazil likely to track her
down but i'm getting a bit ahead of
myself the trapdoor leads lisa outside
her apartment where she is shot by one
of lou's hitmen it's okay because she'll
manage to stay alive until boro later
removes it using magic remember bora
wants lisa's body in good shape as
she'll be taking it over but before we
get there lisa stops at luz who appears
to be on death's door she's been on this
journey of revenge and wants answers why
did he screw her over when he promised
to make her movie have her be the
director and act as her mentor as lou
says
in the car
you moved my hand off your leg
made me feel small lisa can't help but
laugh this whole thing was caused by a
man's fragile ego instead of killing him
the thing she's wanted to do this entire
season she pities him it's also kind of
ironic that lou becomes blinded just
like one of his falcons we'll see him in
the hospital where lisa ends up paying
him a visit and we also get a glimpse of
zelda without her bandages she like lisa
has undergone a transformation of a
different sort her appearance here a
subtle reminder of the vapid superficial
nature of hollywood a world which lisa
wanted so much to be a part of but will
now leave behind lisa visits boro but
ends up confronted by her former lover
and star of her short film mary mary is
pissed because she believes she was
manipulated by lisa into eating her own
eye for the movie for context both were
high on peyote at the time and it's here
that borrow attempts to transfer into
lisa's body but she isn't strong enough
we'll later learn that lisa has to let
her in for the transfer to work lisa
doesn't want that and in order to
disconnect from borrow remember their
link from the ritual they performed in
episode 2 she's going to have to kill
her so she calls her friend roy who owns
a gun and heads back to the witch's den
there she finds her ex has been turned
into a zombie and is being used as
blackmail borrow says she can revive him
if lisa agrees to let her in her body
but things don't go as planned and roy
is beheaded it's a sad ending for him
since just last episode he told lisa
that for the first time in his life he
wants to be alive she makes him want to
live ever since he accidentally killed
his sister in a car accident one in
which he survived unscathed he's
performed death-defying feats to get
closer to death like skydiving for
example he says to lisa you know i die
in all my movies
nobody ever notices that now he'll die
in real life lisa manages to escape and
cries next to the skeleton of a wolf we
saw a group of cats eating it in episode
one but now all that's left is bone much
like lisa she has lost everything the
wolf has been used and discarded much
like many of the characters used each
other and tossed them aside once they
were done with them are you gonna tell
me you've never used anybody for the
sake of making something lisa used mary
boro used lisa lou used lisa it was a
terrible cycle of exploitation that ends
in tragedy for everyone even lisa at the
end of the series lisa gets her film
handed to her on a silver platter big
shot producer alvin sanders gives her
pretty much full control of her movie
but it's heavily implied she doesn't end
up taking it as she never responds to
alvin's voicemails and she leaves behind
her movie in these film canisters lisa's
apartment is now fully covered in vines
in fact it looks like it's turning more
and more into boro's place the spirit
linking the two is evidently still
thriving we see that boro has also taken
over mary's body her old body that of
jennifer has gotten too weak and now she
must take on another seeing as her
attempt to take over lisa's was
unsuccessful lisa books a flight to
brazil and the attendant asks her if
she's going there for vacation to which
she responds she's going home she's
likely heeding the call of the spirit
who asked her to come find her and her
mother's last known location as well as
that of the spirits was brazil notice
she is wearing cherry red lipstick like
the title of the show and also the
flavor of the soda from brazil boro
gives lisa an episode too we also see
the picture fade to white as she
ventures off and the show ends white was
also the color boro was said to have
seen when she sensed that lisa would be
her next body to inhabit white was also
the color of the jaguar i'm sure i
missed a bunch of stuff but i'm hoping
that covers some of the major question
marks of the series let me know what you
thought of brand new cherry flavor in
the comments below thanks for watching
everyone be sure to like and subscribe
and for more bad takes you can always
follow me on twitter and instagram at
thingstoryt until next time remember
daddy loves you very much